hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in his treatise
on freedom of choice one of the issues
that Anselm delves into is how it is
that a person can become what his
student and the the teacher and the
dialogue are calling a servant of sin
this is coming from a biblical context
but if you you know are turned off by
that you can put aside the theological
language and frame it instead in terms
of how is it that a person can become
such that he or she cannot help doing
the wrong things committing an injustice
however you want to frame it so what
we're talking about here is a sort of
state in which a person seems to be on
free and so he begins in chapter 2 the
student says there's something that
bothers me about this ability to send
someone who has abled us in is able to
be the servant of sin since he who does
sin as the servant of sin but whoever is
able to be the servant of sin is able to
be mastered by sin so therefore it seems
that that person in their will in the
choices that they make is unfree they
are able to make choices but the
horizons of their choices or the options
in some way wind up being restricted in
practicality by this disposition or
whatever it is that we're talking about
in terms of being a servant of sin so to
say that that person is mastered means
that they are no longer free in that
respect and Ansem has his teacher
provide a useful analogy that helps to
clarify this to some degree he talks
about a free rich person and a poor
person and unless the free rich person
makes some sort of commitment that you
know quite frankly seems rather
irrational in the scope of this this
analogy that person cannot be mastered
by the poor person that is that the poor
person cannot dominate them make them
make the choices that the poor person
wants rather than those that would be in
the rich person's interest or those that
the rich person would prefer for some
other reason however once that rich
person has made that rather paradoxical
commitment and said okay I will be your
servant the rich person is stuck the
poor person is the master of the rich
person and the rich person can't say it
takes these backsies or anything like
that they are stuck in that condition
and so Anselm says well we human beings
in relation to what this idea that we're
calling sin are in a similar relation
and what is sin we should remind
ourselves that it is a lack of justice
in the will a lack of rectitude of will
maintained saved preserved kept for its
own sake in latin rectitude Innova loan
pathes prompter say satyr Vata that is
an Psalms definition of justice so when
injustice is in the will we're
in a rather bad state now if we jump
quite a ways ahead into chapter 10 we
see some important discussion of how it
is that a creature becomes a servant of
sin and what the effects of this are so
he tells us others the teacher again a
rational nature always has free choice
because it always has the ability to
keep uprightness of will or rectitude of
will for the sake of that uprightness
itself but when free will deserts this
uprightness because of the difficulty of
keeping it then free will subsequently
serve sin because of the impossibility
of recovering uprightness through its
own efforts so then it becomes a wind
that goes out and does not return
so he says indeed just as before having
uprightness no will was able to take it
without God receiving it so upon
deserting the uprightness which has been
received the will is unable to recover
it unless God give it again so the will
once it has damaged itself by choosing
something else by abandoning its own
rectitude of will by not keeping it for
its own sake then it you know it's going
to be in trouble that it willingly
abandons rectitude by willing something
else in preference to it could be money
it could be vain glory it could be
sexual pleasure
it could be vengeance it could be a
whole host of other things
it could even be willing something that
is good but is not supposed to be had at
that particular time and you know the
key thing is here that there's a choice
that has to be made between maintaining
rectitude of will or uprightness of will
for its own sake and pretty much
everything else
the creature chooses the anything else
that doesn't even mean by the way that
it doesn't also will rectitude of will
for its own sake
it just has to will that less strongly
and we'll the other thing
so that that becomes the object of the
will so it abandons rectitude of will
once it's gone it cannot recover it by
itself so the person can't say well you
know I screwed up I'm really sorry
I realized I shouldn't have done this it
wasn't the right thing I'm gonna go back
to where I was there isn't any going
back to where you were not for handsome
nor can you sort of projected Lee you
know will yourself into having that that
rectitude of will that's not going to
work either it's always going to fail
that doesn't mean that you can't will
the right thing at any given time it
doesn't mean that you can't recognize
that you're missing something all of
that is perfectly possible within Anselm
schema
you simply cannot restore in its
integrity rectitude of will and then
maintain it for its own sake within
oneself so another thing that he says
about this is that the will in fact
that's a sort of you know the first
thing is a possibility statement the
second is a moral statement the wheel
actually deserves to always lack
rectitude of will once it's abandoned it
it's it's sort of like you know if we
want to personalize this if you are
dating somebody and then you decide that
you want to you know upgrade and date
somebody else who has other attributes
that you like better and then they turn
out not to be quite so congenial as you
thought and you go back to the first
person the first person is not going to
unless you know there's there's
something else going on there the first
person if they're you know rightly
minded are not going to take you back as
a matter of fact you don't deserve to be
taken back because you chose something
else instead and rightness of will kind
of works the same way except without
this personalization the person who is
abandoned rectitude of will or
uprightness of will in favor of
something else
doesn't deserve to get it back and so
there's a little bit of a side note here
and put this on the board and some says
it's actually a greater miracle when God
restores rectitude of will in a living
human being who is you know asking for
it or you know contrite or something
like that
that's a greater miracle than raising a
dead person from you know their body
being dead to a state of life so it kind
of puts things in perspective there in
Chapter 11 he picks up this interesting
question how is it that a person can
seem to be both a servant and free at
the same time and you know as usual with
an some what's going on here is the
person is a servant in one respect but
free in another respect and these are
both compatible at the same time so he
says if we distinguish clearly we can
see how a person is both servant and
free without contradiction when they
don't have the uprightness or rectitude
of will that we've been talking about
why they never have the ability to
acquire this uprightness when they don't
have it but they always have the ability
to keep it when they do have it so he
says with respect to the fact that he
cannot return from sin he is a servant
so he's a servant and that he cannot by
his own efforts reproduced rectitude of
will within himself so he's a servant to
sin and at the same time he is also free
because if he had that rectitude of will
nothing not even God you know God
himself
can forcibly draw a person from that
rectitude the only way it can be lost is
if the person willingly chooses to
abandon it and that's always done within
some sort of context so they can't in
fact keep rectitude of will when they
have it they just don't have it at this
point in time but were they they have it
counterfactually or perhaps even just
you know five minutes later right
they can ham it they have the ability to
keep it because they have the faculties
of rationality and of will as Anselm
says at a number of points now with all
of this discussion about about servitude
to sin you might say well what does that
actually mean an Ansem only clarifies
that later on in chapter 12 and it's
very straightforward and it's rather
open-ended as well
the translation that we we have here has
that that you know the servitude
consists in nothing other than an
ability to avoid sinning the Latin is a
little bit more terse in potentia a
powerlessness a lack of power a
incapacity known pecan d to not sin so
does this mean that a person who is
lacking rectitude of will can you know
never do anything right they must always
do the wrong thing no it doesn't mean
that at all
it just means that inevitably they're
going to screw up and they're going to
screw up because they have the wrong
motivational structure because they're
not keeping justice in their will for
its own sake or rectitude of will for
its own sake because they don't have it
this doesn't mean that they can't do
some actions that are good this doesn't
mean that they can't recognize their
condition but it does mean that there's
a certain lack a certain privation of
what ought to be there in the person
that will remain until they are somehow
restored to integrity and that will
break that cycle of servitude
you